i i said before i still see myself as an
entrepreneur so to get in when
everything is set and the direction is
clear
is almost like you know too easy right
the fun part is is
to to be there from day one and to um
you know to help shape the
you know the the future and the product
and the team
and so forth welcome to 20 minute
leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lumitec and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford
let's talk early stage investing meet
kobe samborski the founder and managing
partner at glee loud capital partners
kobe a serial entrepreneur at heart with
over 25 years of experience in various
technology and investment fields
co-founded glee capital partners in
2011.
kobe's vision for gleelope was to
provide an environment for a solid
partnership and investment model between
entrepreneurs and investors
kobe brings his previous experience in
building businesses and effective
execution to his role in glillot's
portfolio
his contributions have yielded gloves 10
exits a strong portfolio
and recognition on the top five best
performing vc's worldwide
since 2014 by preckin kobe samborski
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
i'm good i'm good how are you i'm doing
great you you it looks like you're
outside in this beautiful place are you
in israel right now where where about
yeah i'm in israel i'm at uh at my home
in my
backyard and the weather is great as as
almost as always so
yeah good times it's beaut it's
beautiful it's beautiful kobe
i am honored to have you here glee lotus
is one of my you know all-time favorite
funds that i've been following for many
years and and look out for a slide deck
hopefully within
a year or so when i start my own thing
because what what you've been doing with
focusing on deep technology cyber
security ai most recently
raising a growth fund to interact with
those seed investments i think that
there's a lot of lessons to be learned
about how you're approaching the israeli
ecosystem
but also from your personal journey as a
cyber entrepreneur
an ex-8200 officer and and and bringing
that deep technology
enthusiasm and knowledge to the
ecosystem
and knowing how to work with the
entrepreneurs so i'm gonna stop talking
here
but i'd love to to hear a little bit
from you is a little bit about your
journey all the way back from 8200
what what sort of guides you as you go
on these different paths from
entrepreneur to vc
in the ecosystem
all right so that's a big question so i
have to say that to me i'm still an
entrepreneur so you know even what we do
in glee law to me is entrepreneurship so
you know i started my career in 8200 as
you as you mentioned and you know back
in the day
i feel like an old guy now back in the
day it was not you know
trivial to start a startup company right
so uh in my last uh
you know six months or so you know i
started thinking
what's the next step i already had my
mba and i was you know thinking to start
a company but
you know it may sound weird today but i
had no idea how to start a company right
because
i had uh built a you know a business
plan and i i didn't really
even realize that there is there are
people called vcs that will put money in
my company even that it has like zero
revenues and so forth so
again this was uh back in 96. so uh
actually ended up you know uh delaying
my dreams and joined another startup
just to
just to you know get a sense of how
things done which i think i think it's
probably a good advice for most people
kobe i want to fast forward then to to
when you're you're creating your own
startups you're in an
evolving ecosystem that you know it's
starting to exist there's a lot of
excitement you have the idea if you have
the technion you have the nba
you're getting all this feedback what is
what is that ecosystem like you know
you're watching it today
with the proliferation of accelerators
serial entrepreneurs
vcs one the first thing you mentioned is
that you know we didn't really know
about vcs that people would
give you money even if you don't make
money so so what is that you know
entrance to the world like as an
entrepreneur because today anybody
can go online and do a crash course on
how to raise money how to do a slide
deck
and pretty much can guarantee you know
getting through a pre-seed
you know with some with some degree of
difficulty but but share with me a
little bit about your personal
experience
going all the way back then so yeah so
you know when i again started you know
the ecosystem was much uh
thinner there have been a few vcs you
know not as many as today and most of
them were
kind of with financial orientation um
and and and also you know
uh just in in terms of you know numbers
in terms of people you can really
take advice from the the ecosystem was
very very you know
thin um uh we i ended up in my first
stop you know getting money from
you know angel investors and then you
know moving to the states
and then uh things i wouldn't say became
easier but things started you know to
roll out
uh some you know my first company is
entrepreneur i moved to new york
um and then that you know the bill the
big
bubble burst happened um and i found
myself
you know struggling just to to keep
afloat and ended up
uh pivoting to the japanese market
believe it or not and actually saw the
company in japan and you know it was a
very very interesting journey it was not
a big exit but it's it's
been i've done since then as a as a
entrepreneur and also as investors
around
what 12 or 13 other exits but to me
that's the one that i'm probably still
you know most proud of uh be not because
it was big but just because it was in
such a tough environment and i needed to
pivot from
you know us to to asia you know and
actually sold the company in japan
uh in a very very tough market which is
taking to that moment
you're standing there the bubble burst
you're in new york you're not talking
about pivoting you know within you know
an existing ecosystem you're talking
about shifting culturally
shifting professionally i mean it's a
literally a
like a worldly shift so as this as you
know the leader
what what do you have to do at that
moment what is that
moment like for you you know it's it's
it's an interesting question because i
remember one of my
vps uh when the bubble burst he was like
he was asking me you know kobe you were
always like uh
you know pessimistic and now when when
the world is collapsing you then you
start to be optimistic what i try to do
as as a leader is always kind of you
know balance the team
um uh to be honest you know that
a few months before when the bubble was
still you know bubbly uh you know
everyone was so optimistic and i was
trying to calm people down because it
did not feel
real uh then when when everyone
started to be you know gloomy
i i really found i really thought that i
need
to encourage everyone so i think to me i
think to everyone this is really like a
challenge of your you know stamina and
your uh
and your ability to lead because you
know at the end of the day it's very
easy it's
it's it's easy i would say very easy but
it's easy to lead when everything
goes great and everyone is slapping you
on the back and saying how smart you are
and how
you know how much your company is great
and so forth it's
the real challenge comes when things are
different right
and then and um i think you know most
young entrepreneurs don't really realize
you know how how were the
times back then it's like in in one
night from like being the
you know the hottest thing in the planet
and being chased by
investors and so forth you are um
you know not relevant anymore and you
need to
and you need to figure out you know your
own way so so uh
again super proud of it's obviously was
not easy and
also personally um we were a young
couple back then
my wife was pregnant to actually move to
the us so that i could be more with her
and then i started to fly to tokyo you
know every other week so uh
uh so it was also you know not easy
personally wise but
to me you know one of the things that's
most important for an entrepreneur is to
is to be there you know on tough times
and to you know
uh to continue to be you know committed
and to
think outside the box you know on how
you can you can make this cena work and
and again super proud of my work and my
partner
alone that back then was my partner
we really fought and was able to to get
the company
to uh to an exit you know at the end of
the day so um
i mean yeah again crazy times
with that a few other a few other
acquisitions
and and we're in 2011 and you
and you create you help create glillot
partners and today it is one of the most
you know well-known vcs
in the ecosystem and but take me back to
2011.
where is the israeli ecosystem in your
mind what is the thesis behind
coming in with the centered focus on ai
and cyber security
yeah so back in 2011 we actually
created the idea of gloat in 2010 so
back in 2010 the ecosystem was still
you know after two um you know big uh
you know market meltdowns you know the
one of 2000 2001 and the one of 2008
and the ecosystem was uh um
very you know limited and and
problematic so most of the lps i spoke
with
lp's limited partners you know people
that invest in funds they were like yeah
i'm not gonna invest in funds because uh
you know all the investments that i've
done in funds in the last 20 years were
not doing well and this is
acceptable you know after uh you know a
decade of you know two
two major crisis so so the ecosystem was
very
fragile but back then you know our
thinking was that
there's a huge potential in the israeli
uh you know startup ecosystem which now
it's almost trivial but back then you
know people are still arguing because
people
kind of debate still debated you know
the the
important place of startups within the
ecosystem and specifically israeli
startups and
and we said you know startups are the
way to go and israeli startups are going
to be you know
the leading uh ones but we thought it
feels
or vc needs a different model um
it's we felt that it's not just about
you know picking great companies and
just
you know and just that's enough we
thought that
as an investor you must come with a with
a
bigger vision and strategy on you know
how to pick companies and
and so forth and how to help them and
the first thing
it's it's important our strategy is you
know is is being
focused right because you know our
thinking is you cannot really pick and
you cannot really help if you're just
doing every anything here it's you know
right
now b2b is is hot and tomorrow b2c is
hot and then the next day it's gonna be
whatever healthcare if you're jumping
from one thing to the other
it's very hard to pick right and and
more importantly it's hard to
to help because you cannot be you know
you cannot
do anything right so we decided to focus
and it was obvious to us almost to focus
on the areas that israel has an
unfair advantage mainly cyber and other
deep software
technologies which which which also
correlates very nicely with our own
experience so so we pick
those areas that again israel has an
advantage and that
we have a you know big experience in
which which made it uh
which made it comfortable um and then i
think you know the other
important element is that we are um
very involved and very committed to the
success of the companies for us it's not
about portfolio so it's not about
you know okay you know if company x
fails it doesn't matter because we have
10 others or we have
others when after we invested we are
100 committed to get uh you know the
maximum result out of the specific
company which i think is super important
as well
so i think you know those two elements
of being expert you know helping and
being committed is
is probably you know the most important
part in in what we do and this is what
drives
our success right and i think that you
know two interesting
insights here is that one you know i
believe that of the first six
portfolio companies about five exited
some outrageous
statistic like that that i that i heard
you speak at another event
but but i think what even more
interestingly for me you know i wasn't a
part of the ecosystem in 2011 i
you know i came in after i finished my
army service
and and you know so hearing that in 2011
it was different you know we're talking
about ten years ago nine years ago
and really you know we're seeing today
another another israeli unicorn come up
about once a week at this point
and really you think back to 2011 2012
this is when they started
and this you know if you look at the
length of time so so it sounds like yeah
you started glitter just at the right
time but
but you also have a strategy of going in
early right it needs to be early you
mentioned it was
you know you wanted to when there's two
three people in the room
with you you know what is that about why
why go so so early when they barely know
what they're doing
yeah that's that's another good question
and and we'll
we'll uh maybe you know uh at the end of
the answer talk about our our growth
fund which is kind of change this uh
this a little bit but
right i we like to get in early i mean
first honestly because this is at least
in my mind where most of the fun is
right so i i
said before i still see myself as an
entrepreneur so to get in when
everything is set and the direction is
clear
is almost like you know too easy right
the fun part is is to
to be there from day one and to um you
know to help shape the
you know the the future and the product
and the team
and so forth um this is really where the
you know a lot of difference could be
made and i i'm a big believer that you
know the dna of the company is created
you know in the first
you know four months or so with the
first you know four
employees and the first version of the
product and so forth and yeah you
obviously you know from that point you
always are busy and improving and you
cannot you can improve but um
but still there's only so much you can
do the dna is already there so
uh so that's the i think uh a the most
exciting part of the journey and that's
that's uh
where you can make uh you know most uh
you know impact
um um and you know what we have done in
glott we've built a full infrastructure
you know to
to help portfolio companies
uh mostly a very strong network in the
us
um so we have today about a thousand
executives in our network again mostly
american executives
about 10 of them are what we call our
advisors so about 100 people that are
really
you know that we can jump on a phone
call with them you know
like like on a very short notice and
they will help amazing
and again you you can use this help as a
late stage company but if you start
early
you you can save so many mistakes and so
but so much you know waste of time and
money
uh which is so important um
so so talk to me a little bit about you
know the growth fund so in january
of 2021 i open up calculus tech and i
see
because a lot of raises 170 million
dollar growth fund
investing anywhere between 5 and 20
million and my memory is horrible so
maybe i'm
butchering the numbers but but but it's
different
it's a different mindset it's a little
different than a lot of other vcs also
in israel and
it's very different from your original
strategy of going in early
what is so what is this you know this
closing the circle with with
helping now growth yeah
so first you know our own journey and as
i said i look at ourselves as
entrepreneurs as well you know we
started
with the seed stage fund
again lots of focus on cyber and and
related areas
uh and and honestly
not in a bad way in a good way we looked
at ourselves more as a boutique so we
said
we don't want to be big we'll never
measure ourselves on how big we are
we'll measure ourselves on you know what
great returns we provide both to
investors and to
entrepreneurs so so if we're going to
create you know great
returns to to our investors
and by the way now it's already seven
out of eight uh uh
uh successful exits and ten overall so
if you know most of
our entrepreneurs are happy or or even
became rich people with working with us
you know we're in a good place and and
the the the velocity
or the you know how big we are does not
matter i think what really kind of
kicked in in the last you know year or
two
that that the the opportunity in the
israeli ecosystem is really
you know amazing and um
and we we have created to ourselves i
think a very strong platform
is to really take advantage of much more
than you know two
three deals a year which is typically
what we have done
and also you know when you're doing seed
and at least the way we do you cannot do
too much because we really work very
hard with every company so
at the end of the day it's not a very
scalable business
so the thought about the the growth fund
by the way it's not really growth it's
early growth so it's uh companies that
are you know selling
you know maybe two million dollars a
year stream the classical growth is 10
million dollars so we are
you know one notch below uh but again
the idea was that you know we're seeing
so many great companies that for
whatever reason we did not invest in
seed
uh maybe we were not you know smart
enough to realize that they're going to
be great maybe
they did not approach us for whatever
reason uh whatever the reason is you
know there are
much more than you know two three great
companies every year that are being born
in israel you know and even just in our
you know areas so
uh and with with many of them we are um
we are in touch
we we are you know meeting in events
sometimes we help them with connections
so just as an example this this network
of thousand
uh executives you know sometimes they
will ask us questions about areas that
we don't have a portfolio company so
sometimes they'll ask
questions about companies that are not
ours and we
of course we will help them and and make
the connections with
companies and and so forth so we find
ourselves you know helping companies
even outside of our portfolio and
it just makes sense to you know expand
our
our horizons and and invest in companies
that are outside of the portfolio
um we are investing in gilot plus also
in our own portfolio but again most of
the investments are outside of the
portfolio
and the idea is to go to companies that
are in our spaces
um only the best companies so
companies that were raised right you
know even
even that we were not around the table
and obviously there are a lot of those
um and be able to also to provide them
help and support from the position of
later stage investment right
so to make our network available to them
to them in a
uh in a structured in a way um
uh and and and again
being able to take up a bigger part in
the
in this amazing um
um you know growth of the of the local
ecosystem
as you mentioned they're more unicorns
than ever and i'm you know looking
i'm super optimistic now specifically
after 2020
i'm super optimistic that uh we'll see
more and more
it's just it's evident that it will
happen so
so we we are again in our mind it's it's
it's uh
changing the mindset of being you know a
small boutique to being uh
an important platform in the in the
israeli ecosystem
i i love it kobe 20 minutes go by way
way too fast but i do have
one important question before the most
important question
and and so one thing that i'm gathering
from you
is that you know you're an entrepreneur
at heart not only you're you're you're
serial entrepreneur
you know with companies but also as a vc
you start off
with an entrepreneurial mindset saying i
want to work with the entrepreneurs
in in the same small round table helping
them
think of the culture think of the
strategy in the first
months so my question to you then you
know what
what is the one of the things that gets
you so excited when you see an
entrepreneur do something
when you're sitting in front of a
founder what what would they do
as a leader as a thinker strategist that
you say ah that is why i love
entrepreneurship that is why i love
working with founders
give me an example of something like
that
wow that's a great question i think uh
i think to me the most exciting part is
you know this moving for this
this you know move from zero to one uh
you know obviously you know after the
first cell you know there's so many more
things you have to do and the journey
just starts but to me this
this creation this this going from
nothing to something you know to
to a product to a dna of a company to a
a
living it's almost like a living you
know creature that has his own life and
destiny and so forth to me that's that's
uh that's
that's really where the magic you know
happens and uh
and um and so that's that's that and
and you know the the most exciting
things to me are the
you know successful end results but not
necessarily
but specifically for journeys that have
been tough so i mentioned before you
know my own journey
in the first company that was had a lot
of
you know struggles and uh and mistakes
to be honest i've made a lot of mistakes
as
mistakes as a young entrepreneur and
also you know tough luck you know with
uh the bubble burst and so forth and
still you know
guide this ship to a successful end
so to me the the exits that are more uh
you know excited
around our exits or we end results that
came
after you know struggle uh not
necessarily been easy
and uh and you know places where the
entrepreneurs
you're really needed to show guts um
and you know stamina to uh to to guide
their sheeps uh
so you know sometimes you know you have
a you know an exit after two years that
you know nothing really
you know it's it's been you know very
easy which is
that's amazing those typically are you
know
also you know very good in terms of um
financial returns but to me what's more
exciting is companies that are running
on you know longer
that are also again suffering from some
you know tough times
um and still you know finding a way to
uh you know to overcome to me that those
those are the most rewarding uh
situations
kobe thank you so so much for coming
here i i know how busy you are and i and
i so appreciate your time i have
one last short question before i let you
go and that is the three words you would
use to describe yourself
wow uh so i would say first
i said before entrepreneur
[Music]
then wow what would be the second one uh
i think maybe you know drive to success
i mean you know
again i said before even if the journey
is going a bit toughy you know you
should never
you know give up um and uh
for three i would probably say you know
a people's person
uh i always uh um at the end of the day
you know we are we're we're people and
it's
that's you know what really counts all
the all the other stuff is
so it doesn't matter you know if if you
know you're an entrepreneur or an
investor or
you know an employee or you know um
an executive or whatever at the end of
the day you know we are
we all you know people and something
that we all need to remember
i hope i did not go to philosophical
thanks
this was wonderful stay safe and stay
healthy awesome